Christmas
right we'll get underway
thank you Stuart when you're ready
welcome
um counselors and members of the public
to the community wellbeing meeting and
welcome to those joining remotely
are there any apologies for the meeting
please I have apologies from the council
Val councilor Richard mcfowl and
councilor Phillips any other I think
we're all here apart from that
would someone like to move the apologies
please thank you Keith Kink thank you
Ben
all in favor apologies are accepted
please say I Against
carried
are there any Declaration of counselors
conflict of interest for this meeting
none
excuse me minutes of the 21st of
February were confirmed as a true and
correct record on the 18th of April
council meeting
today we have four items on the agenda
and there's a slight change in the
agenda
item three the review of over 80
swimming will be taken first
and we'll change that with the GGC
Reserve management plan
so without further Ado because we've got
one hour for this meeting I'll just call
on Kylie to present her report thank you
Kylie
hi everyone
um we've had over 80s free parking for
over a year now a free parking free
swimming and aqua aerobics so Martin did
want to be here but he's got staff
shortages at the poll so we just wanted
to um
report back on how it's going and the
benefits the older people have seen in
the community from allowing the free
swimming
and so we've had 463 visits from over
80s and 30 individuals in those visits
so it's been the same people using it
over and over which is awesome and the
feedback's been really positive
um we've had comments like absolutely
fabulous it has allowed me to go
swimming every day whereas before I
could only afford to come a couple of
times a week I have been telling my
friends about it it is the only exercise
I can do that isn't painful
it's a lovely gesture I'd hate to lose
it I love it
um and also I just love it and it's a
great innovation
so the pool staff
and ready for living I'm really happy
with how it's gone
money wise
I'm sure you're interested so we've had
a loss of Revenue of 2142
dollars over the year that it's been
operating so
yeah
any questions
are there any questions for Kylie
no
thank you very much for for your report
Kylie and I see that um the over 65 year
olds would also like to have
um swimming fees cut but just not sure
that in what what we're looking at in
our rates that um we will be discussing
that but we could take that to the
long-term plan process
first ascertain conflicts of interest
and that might disqualify normally yeah
thank you
thank you very much Carly great report
so we now move on to the workforce plan
if our point of order
there's a recommendation report be
received and private to the report being
received I would like to comment please
yes and that is that this is a a clear
example where the social benefit that
comes from providing facilities free for
particular groups in the community is
well worth the cost it is to council and
it's something that I fully support
and we should be possibly looking at in
other cases as well
yes thank you very much councilor hoveau
and I'm happy to move the recommendation
thank you
I have a second to please thank you
Council Reed all in favor you have a
comment could I just add a
recommendation there as well uh Madam
chair you mentioned around the 65 age
and above age group potentially wanting
these same benefits create a
recommendation uh that we look at the 65
and above bracket as part of our
long-term plan making that free as well
you'd like to move that you're happy
and you'll second it counselor Hotel
I'm happy to add it to my motion if I've
passed uh made a motion I can't second
an amendment so I'm happy to add it to
mine
so the second for that amendment was
counselor Reed
are you happy with that Amendment
absolutely thank you all in favor
carried
so we now move on to the workforce plan
which will be presented by the manager
in puller
thank you madam chair on your agenda you
have the Google Workforce plan which has
been 10 months in the making with a few
hiccups because we've had some shortages
in our team of Staff but we've we've got
there
there's been
a raft of work done in the space in
Southland with a lot of different
agencies so the aim of this was to pull
all of the work that's been done and get
a good position of what's happening
it was very much about looking at what
needs to happen from a development and
attraction and retaining skills in a
competitive market
that would help our local economy so we
actually did two business surveys over
the last two years in in August we'll be
looking to do a further one and this is
have informed a lot of our work that
we've been doing in the business space
and also with milk hospitals for jobs
I've given you a printed it out which is
an A3
strategy in a page to make it easy for
you so that you can just see but the
majority of our businesses in your
District have a staff of one to five and
there's six businesses that have over a
hundred staff that they employ
um
so that you'll see what the key
challenges there that the strategy
identifies is very much around
attracting our recruiting and training
staff but also retaining them as an
issue often we get and we talk to the
larger businesses people will come to
gore District maybe for a two-year
period and then they may leave and it's
part of a progression in career is what
we're seeing there there's also the
perception around certain industries
I've just been at Health localities
today and when we were talking about
Workforce there's various perceptions
about going into Health sector at the
moment and it's similar for the farming
community
there's quite a lot of discussion around
the Aging Workforce and this is coming
up in the ready for living strategy that
piece of work is happening right now and
that document is actually in draft going
to the working group this week and then
back to consultation with the
stakeholders which is an agency group
and 50 older people in our community
that have been giving up their time for
the development of that piece of work so
we've had some really good feedback from
their perspectives of being older and
what they've experienced in the
workforce and then this document has
very much given us the business
perspective for that sector
um when we were treating people here the
attractive lifestyle of good District
definitely comes up
um businesses see the keys and key
opportunities around digital technology
and developing up appropriate skills
uh then if on the right hand side of
that page just gives you a snapshot of
the sectors so working with job Seekers
and those are some of the things that we
plan to do
the older prisons I've covered off ring
a turkey that is very much the work that
we're doing in mural tassels for jobs
and we've just completed our third year
the first two we had outcomes set at 50
for each year which we well and truly
had and surpassed this year it was
sitting at we had funding for 35
outcomes and we're sitting at 34 right
now and the year finishes at the on
Friday and I'm pretty sure by Friday
we'll have that 35. we've got five
people in an interview stage right now
the Maori piece of this strategy has
been developed with the hokanui railanga
and um
EKU regen through Ivan hodgetts and he's
also very involved in the Ministry of
Education so a lot of the actions within
this section will be in partnership with
them
currently in our district there's a very
small number of Pacifica the current
state say 1.1 percent
and it'll be interesting when we get the
census to see what our data is actually
looking like but that area is very much
on our radar because of RAC workers and
there has been RAC workers that have
come into Court District and we need to
be in a position to be able to support
both the business and those people
coming into our district because they're
generally here for a shorter period of
time and it's how we integrate them into
the community and what processes we have
and that links nicely into the work that
we're doing with welcoming communities
um
people with disability the disability
part of our work in the workforce
actually ties in through metal tasks for
jobs because they shifted the criteria
last year to enable some of that funding
to assist people with disability into
work when we did the business survey
there was a high percentage of
businesses said that they were happy to
employ people who had disability so it's
really about linking people up migrants
this ties closely into the welcoming
communities work
it crosses over with RAC but it also
crosses over when
um like I think Alliance was bringing in
people from Asia for a Workforce we also
end up having people on our books that
actually their Partners have come in
here and there I have a work visa or
they've become a resident and their
partner is looking for work so the whole
accredited employer process
some businesses don't want to do that
process anymore so that actually
restricts who where people can get
placed
and then just that was made the comments
already about retaining a Workforce
which is important you'll remember when
we looked at the funding for Great South
there is the discretionary funding piece
of that
agreement which is sixty thousand
dollars and we've had a discussion with
them around the attraction and retention
work that they're doing and having a
specific piece of work for Gore District
so that is how that will tie those
organizations will try to be there
thank you very much Anne that's a very
comprehensive report in it um shows all
the work that's gone on behind the
scenes thank you
is there any questions for him
Council Hobel
you have highlighted that the district's
employment rate is 73 percent roughly
but the area that we
pull in employment from it's wider than
the gore boundary and I'm just wondering
what employment numbers or percentage
that work in Gore actually live outside
and we're our strongest linkages too
so those statistics are really all we
have available through stats New Zealand
but we're very aware that our community
of interest is greater than the District
boundary and in saying that under
neurotus was for jobs we have worked
with likes of Mindy college and we're
currently working out with fonterra so
there is crossover from outside the
district and if you take neurotusables
as an example there's been situations
where we may fund a business that's
outside the district because the
employees within the district or vice
versa
yeah so it is difficult to get that data
right
um I I have just finished uh reading a
document that's been released tomorrow
which is the Beyond 2025 document and it
has a number of actions in it and the
synergies between what's and let
document and what's here uh overlap
um to a considerable extent and I'm just
wondering if it's worthwhile this
committee actually receiving a report
once the Beyond 2025 document is
released that actually picks up some of
those linkages if the higher area
looking at how do we integrate what's
happening at the regional level with
what's here and I understand there is a
a cell phone
Workforce plan and
the the there are some gains to us in
the district I think by just drilling
down a bit deeper into the various
documents and making sure that we're
integrating them to our full advantage
thank you Council Council hello just ask
um so is it part of this process we've
worked closely with all of those
documents and all of the people behind
those documents
um Bobby Brown I have had a discussion
again this week about when Beyond 2025
is
released coming to council and also the
discussion around having infametrics
come as well because they have produced
a range of reports that have informed
that document so the intention is to
you know do theirs basically the other
comment I should just make around male
task force is just yesterday that we we
heard that we will have funding for
another year our funding in the past has
been 500 000 for each year it will be
considerably less so the potential is
that it's under
um 200 000 this year with outcomes of 24
people
and to work and we currently have 24
people on our books that we're working
with so we'll easily meet that Target no
it's
a
any further questions counselor Reed
thank you madam chair just a question to
Anne
um
the people with disabilities that
employers are looking to have in their
premises is there any funding available
for those businesses to put in
wheelchair accessibility or toilets
things like that any extra for people
businesses in the community
um with various streams of funding but
we tend to refer either the business or
the person to workbridge in the first
instance because they would be working
with the person
um
yeah there is a range of agencies but it
depends that on the specifics yeah
yes two there's no guarantee that that
employment would work out but it would
be nice to think that it made it easier
for some to be able to get jobs so under
milled hospitals for jobs there's
flexibility about what we fund and what
we support and sometimes that support is
actually to the business to do something
like that it might be setting up a
workstation it might be some specialist
piece of equipment or the the funding
can be directly attributed to the young
person and in that case it
um
generally would be around training but
like we have had instances where
somebody started work and needed glasses
discovered that actually they couldn't
see well enough to do the job so and
they didn't have the resources to get
glasses so that was an example where you
know because because that program is all
about getting sustainable employment for
a young person yeah
thank you in any further questions
Council McKenzie
it's just a comment really in
um we want people to come here and stay
accommodation I know some employers use
that as a method of getting people here
but how we achieve that I'm not 100 sure
it's just a comment I'd like to add if
it's a little extra we can add to the
process of well hey look we can get you
accommodation whether it's helping
people get into a house or temporary
that that sort of thing it's just a
comment a lot there
I'm happy to receive that comment we um
definitely have had instances in our
team where we have had people that have
come into the area and we've found out
about them either through welcoming
communities or through the business
getting in touch with us saying they
were struggling with accommodation and
through our wide networks we've
generally managed to eventually sort
something out but we don't have an
active program around that
thank you
thank you any further questions yes you
worship
thank you chair uh not so much of a
question but just a comment and a
congratulations to Ann and the team for
completing this I know this has been an
enormous amount of work and a huge task
um undertaken but there's a lot of
information in this Workforce plan I'm
really going to be really useful
um for our long-term plan discussions
and moving forward I I guess I just
wanted to build on uh councilor
hervell's comments
um around Beyond 2025 in this Workforce
plan do we think it's best to have it
come to council or for it to come to an
ltp Workshop that can also be publicized
so the public can can see us have a
conversation about it just there's a lot
of detail on both this and and Beyond
2025. I'm not too sure which option will
be better and if we needed any
recommendation here today
would you like to come into their team
or go back oh I think that's really up
to the chief is it get around there and
lead to members what you would like to
do
here is clearly some strategic
issues both in this document and in the
other ones that have helped inform it
like Beyond 2025 that are Central to the
council moving forward with its
long-term plan
but at a day-to-day implementation level
there's a whole series of things that we
as counselors need to be thinking about
across the board and through our
different committees so I see two
distinct players that come out of both
this document and and particularly the
priorities where it lists high medium
and low
I think is is
councilors we should be looking at both
so I'd like to see the long-term plan
looking at some of the Strategic issues
and a report to council actually looking
at some of them the more day-to-day
implementation ones
and there are differences
thank you councilor Hotel
comments Steve
this Workforce plan will be useful at
the high end to actually feed into the
ltp
workshop type discussions and I've
actually got a memo for councilors for
the first for the next Workshop of the
ltp and it's Tuesday
so this is all about what type of
community you want what are the issues
how can the council enable things to
take place in a timely way and then of
course there's the nitty-gritty on the
ground stuff which and her team will
Implement so I do agree on that sort of
two tiered approach but there's a lot of
good information here to propel the
community forward
[Music]
questions
yes counseling thank you madam chair
just another question to Ian and it's
probably not around the workforce
strictly but given that we've got a
quickly aging Workforce and population
probably one of the highest in the
country
um
the volunteer base that actually
underpins a lot that happens in our
community how do you see that working
um when people start becoming
leaving the workforce are they still
going to volunteer and do many of the
jobs in the community that um
younger people perhaps don't have time
for
actually in the ready for loving
strategy one of the questions we asked
our older working group of this 50
people in this that we've been liaising
with was around volunteerism terrorism
and there was a mix of responses so some
people said don't want to borrow it done
it all my life running around after my
kids for sport and all the other things
and now it's my time
um that there was other people that said
when you moved to gore it's very
difficult to become a volunteer you need
to be asked
and then there was other people who just
didn't understand that position that
said it was very easy to become a
volunteer here so there's a there's a
quite a mix of opinions within our older
community around the voluntary space
there is a piece of work that under just
Transitions and Beyond 2025 that they
have been doing in the volunteers in
space but we haven't yet seen the
outcomes of that so that may inform us a
little bit better
yeah but there will be some discussion
coming around that in our older people
I'm in our community
so I'm not sure that answers the
question but it gives you as much as we
have right now
thank you any further questions
would somebody like to move the
recommendation that the workforce plan
be adopted
thank you councilor Reed secondary
councilor hovel all in favor
against
carried
are there any further comments about
that recommendation or the workforce
plan
thank you
we'll move on to
do the
delivery the workforce plan report
we've done that sorry we'll do the
review of The Gorgeous Council Reserve
management plan amendments
we have four recommendations
in that plane and I'll just ask the
report
from the parks and reserves manager
Keith macrobbie if you'd like to comment
on that please yeah just through your uh
Madam chair
um just a bit of background to the
management plan process
um I think Gore District Council has
been well served by previous parks and
reg managers and I think going back
probably to Gordon Bailey's era
um
yeah there's been management plans in
place and I think through the whole time
a company called exist have been
involved in the review so
um yeah the current plans we're in place
are approved in 2016 and
um I think that that classed as what you
would call Omnibus
um
management plans over volume one is
around general policies around
parks and reserves Volume 2 is around
individual Reserve so it's a smaller
smaller reserves volume 3 is the green
belt Reserve so that's essentially from
vehicle Street playground right up to
Bannerman Park and Preston Street so
that's that body of that group and then
the final volume volume four is Donald
Park so that's quite a
significant Park in its own ride in
quite quite unique compared to the
others so
um so exists have yeah have been
involved
for a long time so that they um their
current staff were involved in the 2016
and update and um so we we've reviewed
them again with exist
in terms of the work involved one of the
initial things was through Neil Mayer
and that was around
leases and buildings and structures on
on reserve so there's obviously that
sort of Deeds updating on a relatively
regular basis and
Neil's tidied up that space considerably
so um yeah some of the information
it's probably well it's a whole lot more
accurate than it's ever been I would
suggest
um the next item was really around the
images of the um of the reserves which
were on the management plans and um
I think the previous aerial photographs
were all done around 2002 so we're
probably quite at out of date and um
so I've got you know the the Aerials
were flown last summer I think the
previous summer and so a whole lot more
accurate in terms of
I guess boundaries and things like that
so yeah it's a very very good
um the next item was around there was a
whole lot of recommendations and
programmed works
and some of it if it's just really been
an update so some of the work has
happened some of the work hasn't
happened some of some of the work is no
longer relevant so again that's been
updated and then the last thing that I
guess it happened really is
um
we have to consult with
Tanga definite so it was a discussion
with Ricky Paratha and his team and
they've come forward with a whole lot of
recommendations so
um and I'm not sure of
um
how that compares to previous but um you
know I would suggests there's a number
of things in there that um
by way of example
um you know one of their recommendations
is that um
should be consulted regarding events on
all events on Parks and Reserve so um
I'm just I I think well while it's a
legitimate
um
request
um you know practically speaking
um I'm not sure if they've got really
any interest saying
um the park run at Hamilton Park on a
Saturday morning or um or the
Rhododendron day and you know called
public gardens in October so um so I I
think there's um there's certainly some
work to be done in that space and the
other the other one that I think
probably raises its head a wee but as as
around the um
I guess the use of dual language on Park
signage
we've probably got
a very small number of the new signs
that have been done using the
council's sign manual
um and it was was a small amount of
Maori proposology on those but you know
the generally our signs really are um
uh you know probably 99 in English so
you know it's it's it's
um
it's it's a big journey and it's
probably a much wider issue than
it sits just at Justin the park space so
um
yeah so I I think yeah there is there is
definitely some work to be done
um between Council and the the Rooney
just to just to work through
you know I guess all the requests really
yeah
so that's thank you
thank you thank you Keith excuse me any
questions for Keith please
Council Reed thank you madam chair
um just around the renanga going forward
would we be looking at would there be
something in the ltp that we could be
looking at to and
have both languages Incorporated on new
signage
in the Parks and Reserves
I think it's a wider issue really yeah
yeah you know I think that there needs
to be a
conversation with a conversation yeah
counselor
I've got three areas I'd like to explore
as part of this report
the world has changed a lot since 2016
and the way that our parks and reserves
is changing as well both in terms of the
membership of organizations that are
using them aging of population
and I I think it's desirable that that
we actually give an opportunity for the
users of our parks and reserves to have
some important to this process
what set out in in the reporters that
under Section 5A of the result of
sequence 41 of the reserves act Council
was not required to give people the
opportunity to comment but I believe we
should and under subsection 9 we're able
to do that if we're of a mind
what is required and in terms of what's
set out there is is giving public notice
of the intent to review the plan and
providing an opportunity for written
suggestions as to things that should
happen and I I believe we should be
given the opportunity to the public to
speak up in terms of the things that
have changed what the people's users
aspirations are of the parks so from
that point of view what I would actually
like when I get to the inter movie first
part of the recommendation that we do
provide an opportunity for the public to
give comment
the second matter I want to raise is in
relation to dogs
the Croydon Bush Recreation reserve and
the conservation management strategy
allows dogs to be present in the reserve
and as a rhetorical question I would
actually like to see some public
discussion about the extent to which
dogs are permitted in our reserves Gore
has a slightly different approach to a
number of other areas and there's less
opportunity on one day I was going to
take my dogs for a walk along the dock
Reserve area and decide to go out to the
park and saw some signs on the council
in saying no docs so I was left a little
bit confused and I'd like to see some
public discussion take place on that I
would also like to see some public
discussion take place on the bilingual
sign issue it is wider than reserves it
could apply to a number of things but is
the reserves a nice tidy package in
which to consider it because I believe
the cultural values they're assigned to
many of our reserves and the like uh
different to other situations and it may
be that they are a different thing to
consider all together
the next point is I'm interested in
terms of and again it's a rhetorical
question for staff but I believe it
highlights the need for um more public
input and that is what regard was given
to the gore parks recreation and
facility strategy of
2019. for example on that strategy it
talked about additional seats and
um in in parks and the cemeteries it
talked about review of paid play
equipment and in some areas in a page 53
of that document it refers to a
rationalization of assets reading the
quote we are over Supply or redundancy
is identified I think that Reserve
management plan process is the opportune
time for us to consider the reserves
that we hold and whether we it is
appropriate to have them moving forward
bearing in mind the management plan
continues for 10 20 years what is the
structure we want for reserves we have
some of the highest areas of reserves
per person of the size District do we
need them all are they in the right
place maybe some of the reserves that
we've got like we did a swap
um on other land and can be swapped over
um and the um that strategy also
highlights what's been talked about
before a trimmed a more passive
Recreation and again does that mean that
we should be looking at slightly
different approach to our reserves so
taking those things all together I'd
actually like to see the public having
an opportunity providing comment and for
a more thorough
drilling down of the reserve C6 that
we've got and what framework do we want
moving forward
thank you councilor hoveau would you
like to comment to that
do
we would be the best place to drill down
on Parks and reserves well I think
Manchester what council Hove our raises
is a
an interesting point in terms of how we
go about our decision-making process in
2023 versus what may have traditionally
been the case under the reserves act
which causes written in 1977 language
and so the ability of people to actually
participate in the process and come
forward with ideas is generally
considered to be best practice in the
modern era and so therefore I think it
wouldn't hurt us at all to actually go
down that track and ask for the Public's
input before we come up with a draft and
before it then goes out for formal
consultation because as calcified
correctly surmises that Recreation
changes and there could be things that
we haven't thought of that into the
community might might suggest that
should be catered For in a specific
Reserve or reserves generate so I can't
see any harm in fact I honestly just a
lot of good coming out of an early
Community engagement getting some ideas
and then finalizing a draft which then
goes back out to public for formal
consultation
foreign
following any other comments counselors
have got I'd like to actually
um playground with um what the
recommendation is please thank you
councilor Hotel
yes thanks councilman McDonald oh I
support what councilor Valor said I just
uh so but I want to actually just hone
on at one point here and become very
obvious the plank at least has expired
on the society and the building has
surrendered I want to know perhaps from
Neil or someone what are we going to do
with that building and can we do
something with it that actually makes
money
rather than become a liability that
we're going to maintain
through Madam chair the situation at the
moment with that building is that was
just recently
Plank and abandoned it it was set up for
the sole purpose of a blanket Reserve
but for several years they've probably
been
not quite abiding by that in the means
that midwives were using it which are
not directly plugged
the building is
being used for storage at the moment
and but it is able to be moved
and there has been discussion in the
past of possible areas elsewhere in the
council where that building could be
moved to
but I can't say any more in the open
meeting
because it is just ideas
so no it's not going to cost
relinquished there because really it
needs to be removed so we can revert
that back to its proper Reserve status
thank you
yes you worship
thank you madam chair I just had a
number of questions or one question one
comment uh page 10 5.2 1.5
um that is the Richmond Street Community
Center Point two has been removed that
says no new buildings will be erected on
the site I was just wondering why that
is
uh page 10.5.21.5
is through the cheer
um when I was going through this
original documentation
um
I believe that at that time this was
just changing the information that was
on
within the document and there was no new
buildings looking at going on that land
we've demolished two
in the last few years to tidy it up and
then there was no plans for any
any other buildings to go on there at
that stage
okay so it's not a restriction it's uh
it was there was there was no plan to be
any new okay cool thank you for that
clarification the second one I was more
of a comment and it kind of Builds on
from uh Keith's points around a bit more
further work with uh the hokanuranga so
page 24
uh Point D
um it states or the the recommendation
States uh if no suitable occupy can be
found in the building or structure
cannot be relocated and there's no
reasonable for civil use for the
building or structure that will be
offered offered to the hook and arunanga
uh and then it goes on with if the hook
and arunanga decide to
decline the offer to acquire the
building and it'll be demolished I just
had some concerns with that around
maybe the the timeline of how that would
work I just think of things like the the
Matilda Paul where we've decided to
demolish it the way I read this
um and the pull might be a bad example
but the way I read this is that we would
have to offer it to the runanga and they
may want to use that building which
means we then can't demolish and use
that land for other other purposes
um is that is that other people's
understanding teeth or
this is just what they've requested so
yeah it's certainly not um and play as
such yeah
there's a concern they're moving forward
thank you
thank you welcome
um councilor Richard mcvale are there
any other questions
councilor hoval just just before I um
put the the motion
um I'd be interested in some feedback
from counselors in terms of
what input they would like to have to
the preparation of the draft is this
case where possibly we should be looking
at a subcommittee or do we leave it to
staff to work away and then come back
there's some benefits in either
direction and um
yeah depends on the mood of counselors
before I would the recommendation
would it be better that this was decided
at a full council meeting councilor
Hotel
in order to do that then it would
probably be appropriate to still put a
recommendation in there for Council to
consider
and I can word it along those lines so
if if it's agreeable I'll move three
motions of for me
so you're changing the recommendations
that yes before that you have you accept
the last one
um I'll take you through step by step
okay so with with the first
recommendation
um I would move that the council resolve
to review the goal Reserve management
plan volumes one to four full stop
number two that the council resolve in
accordance with section 41-9
of the reserves act to seek
um
written I just want to use the section
there are the words that are here
um
that the council seek reference
suggestions
for
and it doesn't matter from it so the
council receives written suggestions on
on the future use of Reserve areas
number three
I don't believe we need at this stage
that is appropriate once a draft has
been prepared and and reported back nor
do we need number four at this stage but
given the conversation we just had a new
number three that the council give
consideration to the establishment of a
working party
to assist staff in the preparation of
the draft Reserve management plan
just
yes Steve yeah just once just a little
chair to assist the Council and staff
providing Clarity with the move uh
prefer to change the world rather than
consider developing uh or a working
party to a will establish a week yes
because we can still have that
conversation yes
any questions or comments from well I've
moved so I guess we need a second
under
you worship
any further comments or questions
are we all in favor
do we all understand the recommendations
or would you like them Bridge back yes
please
Reserve management plan volumes one to
four
second one was
that the council resolve in accordance
with Section 419 of the reserves act to
seek written suggestions on the future
use of Reserve areas
and the last one was that the council
established a working party to assist
staff in the preparation of the draft
Reserve management plan
um do we need actually written
suggestions from whom the public rate
payers do we need that put in there
could you use your speaker police
Council yes seeking Britain's
suggestions in terms of section 41 5 of
the reserves act and that sets out step
by step thank you councilor Reed
to all the councilors happy with that
all in favor say aye
against
carried
and welcome councilor Paul mcphail
foreign
report from active Southland and I
believe that um parts and Recreation
manager is set
okay there is nobody here from active
South and
so we'll just take the report then as
read yeah my apologies I haven't even
read the report on that I'm sorry
take the report
in
um ask for any questions please
thank you
I'm happy to move the recommendation
report be received
thank you councilor how about
secondary
you worship thank you I just like to say
that I think physical activity is great
for our um
for school children and their children
and and learning how to swim I think is
most important as well so it's a very
thorough report and I think it it does
assist the health of air
of our children
uh two I look forward to the um the
funds when they're available to upgrade
Oxford and Hamilton Park I think um
that's a very good idea to help with
disabled children and other children
that can't use the park and some new
equipment
to thank you counselors
so that brings us to the end of today's
meeting
or his
counselor about and you seconded it
oh all in favor
against carried
thank you for attending today and thank
you for coming along to the meeting and
I'll close the meeting thank you